[Music]
[Narrator:] The American Medical Association presents a special report in compatible color.
Ladies and gentlemen, the vice president of the United States, Richard M. Nixon.
[Vice President Nixon:] How do you do? In a few moments you will see a March of Medicine Program entitled MD International.
I'm pleased with this opportunity to introduce it because I believe wholeheartedly in what it has to say.
President Eisenhower in his State of the Union message on January 9 stated,
"The only answer to a regime that wages total cold war is to wage total peace."
In this day of great concern with weapons in our search for security and peace,
this program documents a power some of us often overlook.
It is the force for good that lies in the basic brotherhood of man.
In my travels around the world I've often observed how a hand outstretched in friendship,
a heart full of goodwill, can do more to win the affection and support of people
than all the guns in our arsenal.
The program you're about to see demonstrates this.
It is the story of American doctors fighting disease in distant, remote regions of the world,
helping fellow human beings to a better life.
Through their humane work,
they are making a positive contribution to the structure of peace.
Of course there are other ways to strengthen the bonds of friendship throughout the world.
By helping other nations to improve their agriculture, their commerce, and their industry,
for example, our people can create a beneficial climate for greater international understanding.
And this is so essential to all our hopes for world peace.
Because our doctors abroad so bolster these hopes,
we can regard their work as that of unofficial American ambassadors.
And at a time when we hear much of man's inhumanity to man,
they reveal our greatest hope for the future, man's humanity to man.
That is why what you are about to see is so important to all of us.
[Narrator:] These are the changing patterns of the face of mankind.
From the lips of such as these, in a hundred strange languages
comes a distant, unending cry for surcease from pain, and preservation of life.
Today we mark some who answer that call, American doctors on alien shores,
whose dedication to humanity lights up our hope
for peace and understanding in the far corners.
[Sounds of heartbeat]
[Music and background heartbeat]
[Narrator:] The map of the world is more than seas and continents.
It is as well the outline of its peoples,
each perhaps drawn a bit differently and colored by the creator
with a different crayon but all kin, one the member of the other.
[Music]
This is the outline of the people of Pusan, Korea.
So airplane-small is the world today
that whatever happens to these people
defies boundaries and barriers to affect people everywhere.
Street market or supermarket, such differences mean far less
than our basic similarities,
and what alone holds the promise of healing our divided world
is our concern one for the other.
The story we bring you is of a special breed of men fired with just that concern,
love of their fellow man.
It is the tale of American physicians who have put on seven-league boots
to giant-stride across water and land,
and pause at the bedside of the world,
to lift the burden of disease from the backs of the family of man.
We will meet them not only in Korea,
but in Hong Kong, Burma, Sarawak, India, Nepal, Lebanon, Ethiopia.
[Music]
But first, first here in this alley in Pusan.
She whose back is tallest is clothed in the robes of the Maryknoll Sisters of St. Dominic.
She and her sisters who live here are devoted to the sick, the halt,
the lame, the blind, and to this their clinic come the troubled ones.
Look upon their faces and read for yourself their story.
The poor from the huts and shanties.
The homeless from the streets,
refugees swept south by the communist tyranny in North Korea, and the life-tossed.
They await only the opening of the gate.
[Music]
And now to reap the day's harvest of illness nurtured in the overcrowded city below.
Former patients under continuing care present
the token of their previous visit and pass inside.
[Babies crying]
Then along the line to extract the seriously ill,
that they may be cared for at once.
[Nun speaks to woman, who replies in Korean]
[Babies crying]
[Nun continues to speak to people standing in line]
[Narrator:] A bond of pain have all in common,
the wrinkled grandmother, and the wide-eyed innocent child,
pain that oft times strikes them down as they wait.
Thus is an act of the prelude to another day ahead
as the nurse reports to the superior, Sister Angelica.
[Sister Angelica:] We have an awful lot of patients out there, we won't be finished early I'm sure
[Nurse in white robes:] I have one little boy here I have to bring in though.
[Sister Angelica:] Take the worst ones first.
We'll seen more than a thousand patients a day coming through these gates
before we close them at 5:30.
People with every imaginable disease.
We have no hospital, but we're building one now.
We're just a clinic with no beds, so we treat them the best we can,
and send them home, to return if necessary.
We have four sister-doctors and several Korean doctors and nurses on our staff.
You will see them working inside to take care of these people.
[Narrator:] Sister Gilmary, Women's Medical College of Philadelphia.
Home, York, Pennsylvania.
[A woman standing next to the child she has brought in for treatment speaks in Korean.]]
[Sister Gilmary:] This little 14-year-old girl was carried on the back of her grandmother
from the country to our clinic for treatment.
She has a case of tuberculosis of the bone.
We plan to treat her by putting her back into a plaster of Paris cast,
which will prevent further crippling deformity of the bone.
It will also alleviate the severe pain which she now has,
not only from the back but also from the abscess here.
With the use of the new drugs for tuberculosis,
as well as supplementary treatment with milk, food, and vitamins,
we hope at the end of two years to have this little girl
walking and playing like other children.
[Narrator:] Sister Maria [?], Marquette Medical School. Home, Cincinnati.
[Sister Maria:] This 53-year-old lady, Sun Yung Na,
was brought to our clinic this morning.
She has had in the past week severe symptoms of heart failure
with a history of rheumatic heart disease since she was 30 years of age.
She has had eight children and has gotten along well until now.
She has severe symptoms of pitting edema of all extremities,
ascites, enlarged liver and heart with a murmur.
We hope to be able to help this lady somewhat,
but her prognosis in general is very poor.
[Narrator:] Sister Lois, Marquette Medical School. Home, Hudson Falls, New York.
[Sister Lois:] This is Kim [?].
He was brought into our clinic approximately one month ago by his mother.
The child's initial problem was one of infectious diarrhea.
At the time of admission, he had a temperature of a hundred and four, six.
We found, however, that the diarrhea and infection were a secondary problem.
The child had been on his right side for approximately one month,
and his malnutrition is his major problem.
We'll continue to feed the child parenterally for a few weeks,
until he's able to take food by mouth,
and in a month or two he should look normal and healthy again.
[Music]
[Narrator:] As the day wears on and medications are dispensed,
the city beyond as well beckons the Maryknoll Sisters with their healing arts.
Each afternoon, Sister Gilmary,
accompanied by a Korean nurse and immaculate in her white robes,
plunges into the squalor of this suddenly expanded city
on a home visit to a patient with tuberculosis,
picking her way up an eroded hillside
that is the front and back yard for hundreds
who must live in tents or can boast only a oil tin roof over their heads.
She struggles up the steep path herself,
that her TB patients may be saved the exhausting journey to the clinic for treatment.
[Rapid speaking in Korean]
This one room is all the home there is for the entire family,
living room, dining room, bedroom, kitchen.
Not only is the mother sick with TB,
but already father and child show traces
of following her down the same threatening road, but for this help.
[Nun speaks to family in Korean.]
And now en route to another patient go the sister and her nurse.
[Music]
Thus is one day done, one day ended, as the gates to Pusan close behind them.
America? America is 6,000 miles away and in their spirit and in their hearts.
Moving south and west across the China seas,
the March of Medicine halts in the shadow of red China to visit another American doctor.
[Music]
In Hong Kong, for centuries they said to one another,
if leprosy can be cured,
salted fish can live again.
But here in 1946 appears a young pathologist from Chicago to teach at the University of Hong Kong Medical School.
He rouses the community to fight leprosy, Hansen's Disease,
until finally, not far from this communist island,
the people of Hong Kong plucked hope from the sea.
They call this island, Hei Ling Chau, the Isle of Happy Healing.
And to this once barren place they move the long despised,
disgraced and banished, to help them.
And now a small launch comes bearing an interesting cargo:
final-year medical students brought to break down their preconceived notions of leprosy, by Dr. Olaf Skinsnes,
the man from Chicago whose inspiration the island was.
He reminds them that the disease is not mysterious, punishment from the gods,
not venereal, not inheritable, but scientifically explained and medically treatable.
Here Dr. Skinsnes will leave them for a week,
the island their classroom and international staff their teachers,
before he returns again to review and summarize their findings.
The next day the students are greeted by Superintendent Dr. Neil Frazer,
who as China representative of the British Mission to Lepers,
helped make the island a reality.
No time is wasted in facing the young students
with the different evidences of the disease,
a disease which Dr. Frazer explains,
as he points out some of its features,
rarely if ever kills by itself,
and of all the infectious diseases we know,
one of the least catching.
[Music]
Choosing children housed on the island,
he declares children the most susceptible to the ravages of Hansen's bacillus,
which is often passed to them on contact in infancy.
The students settle down to a week's labor,
learning to overcome their fear of the disease by taking smears of patients
to confirm the diagnosis of leprosy,
examining the bacilli, breaking up under [?],
studying bone changes responsible for much of the crippling,
and finally they come not to be afraid of treating the patients themselves.
Thus does each day bring a new understanding of the disease,
as the students come ultimately, in sight and sound of boats in the harbor,
to sit with Dr. Douglas Harmon of the island staff.
[Dr. Harmon:] One thing that I want you to keep uppermost in your mind
is that modern medicine can help these patients,
and that with careful research,
the progress that we have made in the treatment of their procedure in the last 15 to 20 years
has made greater strides than in all the centuries before.
This is a picture of a patient with lepromatous leprosy.
Now I want to show you something.
[Music]
This is that same patient that you see in the picture there after a few years of treatment.
And I think you will agree that with our modern drugs
and with what we know about the disease now,
that there is a real hope for recovery and for a useful life,
and that this man is well on the way.
I would like you to remember this man when someday,
someone looking as he did before treatment comes into your office.
[Narrator:] Later they watched the rehearsal of the lepers' production of a classical opera
as they await the return of the doctor who brought them, their fears now dispelled by knowledge.
So when at last the time comes to return to school with Dr. Skinsnes,
they've come to recognize these sufferers as fellow human beings
who can benefit from the same medical science and ideals they apply to other patients,
thanks to the young doctor who came to Hong Kong from Chicago
and his colleagues on Hei Ling Chau.
[Music]
Southward to the equator now,
and the Malay Archipelago to Sarawak in northwest Borneo, sweeps MD International.
These are former head hunters,
the patients of still another American doctor who has carried his talents far from home.
Iban tribesman, 213,000 of them living among the orangutans, the cobras,
the leopards in the steaming equatorial jungle that is Sarawak.
Here along the Rajang River in the land of the communal longhouse and the longboat,
amid mangroves and sago palms,
the forest has been cleared and a hospital raised where Dr. Harold Brewster,
a Methodist missionary, assisted by Dr. Deng,
has settled down and opened his black bag.
[Dr. Brewster:] Our health problems here in Sarawak are threefold.
The number one health problem is malaria.
But the World Health Organization has a group here carrying on a campaign of DDT
to eliminate this problem and in a few months we're going to see the effects of this.
The second problem which we have here is tuberculosis.
We're cooperating with the government by case-finding and treatment of cases
that we find with streptomycin, PAS and IMH, which the government supplies us with.
The third big health problem is intestinal parasites and the dysenteries.
Of course this is tied in with lack of sanitation and ignorance of the rules of good health.
We feel that it doesn't really solve anything to have these patients
just come to the hospital and get treatment,
and so we have a team which goes out, composed of a doctor,
a public health nurse, an Iban helper, and a driver.
We go out regularly in our longboat to the longhouses
and live with the Ibans three or four days at a time.
[Doctor speaks to patients one by one, in their native language]
And besides treating the patients,
we teach them the rules of health and hygiene
which will enable them to live healthier lives.
We do this by showing movies of health films and just sitting down with them
in the evenings and talking to them,
and explaining to them how they can be healthier.
[Narrator:] Such is Dr. Brewster's medical work in Sarawak,
where he struggles to bring the lifesaving promise of modern medicine.
North and West travels MD International,
skirting Thailand and the Gulf of Siam on its way to Rangoon, Burma.
[Music and chanting]
The air is filled with prayerful chants for rain.
As the hot sun, the same sun that fires the golden pagodas, parches the land.
From the Pazundaung, Kipling's waking, winking wonder of the East,
the prayers to Buddha echo throughout the whole city,
even to Rangoon's General Hospital, and in its wards.
The patients know him as Dr. Green, orthopedic surgeon in charge.
But they don't know how he went from Harvard to Turkey
or the years spent with Yale in China Medical College.
Today, Dr. Phillips Green is visiting professor at the University of Rangoon,
often consulting with his Burmese colleagues such as Dean Minh Sang
of the medical college whose patient, a Buddhist monk,
is afflicted with tumor masses, disease nerve coverings,
diagnosed as neurofibromatosis.
And now Dr. Green comes to Yung Sanyoni
who at 15 during the war was hit by an exploding bomb
that killed his parents and took his left leg below the knee.
If Sanyoni is to be helped,
a piece of shrapnel still embedded in the lower pelvis,
causing a mid-thigh chronic drainage must be removed.
The doctor studies the x-rays in anticipation of the operation he plans.
As he scrubs, his thoughts go back to the story Sanyoni told him
of searching for help in vain,
of his visit to a spirit woman in the hills,
seeking a miracle that never came, of his despair of ever walking again.
The plan is clear. First, to remove the shrapnel as is being done here.
This to be followed by revision of the stump,
repairing the painful bony spur at its end.
This done, on to the next step, preparing for an artificial limb.
Sanyoni watches, with hope mounting, the making of the mold of his stump,
but actually far more than that, the overture, so to speak,
for what most of us accept as a matter of course, life on two feet.
And now, after the casting and the measuring and the straightening through physiotherapy,
comes the most exciting day he has ever known.
Where once was only one leg, now are two,
one artificial and strap-controlled,
to go with the one that is flesh and blood.
And in step with the man who made it possible, Sanyoni walks.
[Music]
And at last in answer to the Buddhist chant,
the long thirsty earth he moves upon drinks of rain.
[Music]
This time northwest soars the March of Medicine
above the land mass that is India, to remote Nepal,
at the roof of the world.
To this Himalayan kingdom whose surrounding bastions
have long served to seal it from the rest of the world.
Yes, to this place too,
have come American doctors, to Kathmandu,
capital of the land of the gods, lying in a rice-sown valley,
crossed by a sacred river, rich with a forest of shrines
dedicated to Shiva the destroyer, and Buddha.
[Music]
[Dr. Fleming:] We came here from India in 1953.
My husband had been here previously for the Chicago Natural History Museum.
[Narrator:] You are listening to Dr. Bethel Fleming
of Bucks County, Pennsylvania.
[Dr. Fleming:] We became very attached to Nepal,
learned to like the people very much,
and were delighted when the government
asked us to set up a medical program for maternal and child care.
I arrived with only a little pocket set of instruments,
just an obstetrical forceps and a stethoscope.
Our first hospital was part of this old cholera hospital.
That's all that was available.
Then we moved here to Shanta Bawan,
a former palace,
where we have since grown to include two women's wards and a men's ward.
[Narrator:] Wandering the hospital grounds,
Dr. Fleming finds time for a couple of favorite patients.
[Dr. Fleming:] This is Vishnumaya.
She was discovered by the king while he was making a journey about eight days from here.
Poor thing had club feet and was literally walking on her ankles.
He sent her to us with a message to do what we could for her.
Look at her now.
This man is a Sherpa porter.
He was a guide for a British climbing expedition.
Three men were lost, buried by an avalanche.
This fellow lost his footing. He fell 200 feet.
[Dr. Fleming speaks Nepali to the patient.]
[Narrator:] The eyes of this mountain man as he waits full of longing,
and the eyes of the all seeing-consciousness are fixed on the Himalayas beyond Kathmandu.
Snow-crowned, the highest of them, their names conjure a spell, Annapurna [?].
Challenging their foothills and preceded by porters carrying supplies and camera equipment,
the March of Medicine, in search of still another American doctor,
perhaps more remote and inaccessible then any,
move for two days on foot along this rocky, winding trail toward a town called Tansen.
[Music]
The paths cut into the mountainsides are known as well
to Dr. Friedrichs [?] of Reading that he calls home,
for time and again with only a pack on his back
he must travel them as his highway to reach a patient in need.
And often, return with him up the steep slopes to his hospital.
[Music]
This is Tansen, astride the trail to Tibet,
and this is Dr. Friedrichs' hospital.
In this isolated area, north to Tibet and who knows how far beyond,
there is no other modern hospital.
Later, the doctor diagnoses his litter case as kala-azar,
black fever, a fly-borne disease often affecting the liver and spleen.
In his primitively equipped ward he makes the rounds with his nurse,
seeing first a TB patient,
then encouragement to a little boy who, no different than any child anywhere,
broke an arm falling out of a tree.
And finally tending a man severely burned
when he rushed into his flaming house to save what belongings he could.
[Music]
On the way to his semiannual checkup of the schoolchildren,
Dr. Friedrichs passes through the marketplace of Tansen,
streets incidentally that have never known the wheel;
meets there a young lady whose broken wrist he once repaired.
He continues on, greeted with a friendly shake of the head
by those who have come to know the meaning of the word doctor through his efforts to help them.
[Music]
Gradually some kind of order is restored as the doctor tackles his first customer.
Scabies, TB, malnutrition.
These are diseases the doctor looks for,
noting any evidence of them in a record book
and following up later with his recommendations.
As for the children, a doctor to feast their eyes upon,
to thump their chest with his fingers and listen with his magic earpiece.
These strange wonders come to their Himalayan hills are payment enough.
And so from mouth to ears, with the headmaster looking on approvingly,
the checkup happily continues.
[Music]
But finally with his assistant's help,
the work is concluded,
and turning over the records until next time,
the doctor moves from one of the most pleasant aspects
of his remote practice to confront a more serious challenge.
From the distant countryside miles from Tansen comes one dread word, cholera.
On the only means of rapid movement in this area
go the doctor and his aide for the two-day journey
out to a village in the path of the oncoming disease.
They pause at the sight of the doctor's new hospital
being built on land donated by the government,
land no one else wanted because of the name,
the Wedding Place of the Ghosts.
They push on,
passing through a settlement en route.
And finally, after a night on the trail,
they reach the village threatened by the epidemic
and prepare to apply modern medicine as a barrier
between it and the ancient disease.
As the young and curious look on, the inoculations get underway.
Each protective injection amusingly saluted.
[Music]
But as always when he visits a village,
there's more than one thing to concern the doctor.
Here, for example, a child gored by a bull.
And so is one village made safe as medicine can help make it
against the scourge of cholera, and the long trip home begins again.
[Music]
Hours later as night begins to fall and the winds promise a storm,
they hasten to the protection of a rude shelter,
and here will Dr. Friedrichs sleep.
In the mountains of Nepal, as far from Reading, Pennsylvania as a man can be.
And now, President of Smith, Kline and French Laboratories, Mr. Francis Boyer.
[Francis Boyer:] How do you do?
We're seeing a really inspiring story, a story being written by American doctors
throughout the world,
carrying their healing art to people less fortunate than ourselves.
Perhaps too many of us take for granted the equally inspiring story here at home,
the story of the doctors who are making our own lives longer, happier ones.
Let me remind you of just a few things the medical profession has done for us,
right here in the United States.
This is one of the new heart-lung machines.
During operations on the heart, it acts as a detour,
actually carrying the blood around the heart.
This machine gives the surgeon a relatively dry, bloodless area in which to work
and enables him to perform delicate heart operations hitherto impossible.
Here is a child crippled by polio.
Where once it was commonplace to see little children struggling in braces such as these,
soon it will be a rare sight.
Today, thanks to the Salk vaccine, paralytic polio is on the ropes.
Another example of what our doctors are doing for us:
you may have read not too long ago,
an article about the closing of the famous Trudeau Tuberculosis Sanitarium
at Saranac Lake.
Not only has the death rate from TB declined by more than 50 percent
in the last 10 years,
but the length of time spent by the average TB patient
in a sanitarium has also been cut in half.
Finally, let's take a trip to a modern psychiatric ward.
Until 1956, each year there was an increase in the number of patients
in our state mental hospitals.
Last year, for the first time there was a reduction of almost 7,000 patients.
This is the result of an unprecedented discharge rate.
Today for the first time,
there is new hope in the area of mental illness.
Yes, ladies and gentlemen, your doctor at home, likes his colleagues abroad,
is dedicated to the task of conquering disease.
And because of this dedication,
our nation is one of the healthiest in the world.
May I add just one last thought?
The mission of the pharmaceutical industry of which Smith, Kline and French is a part
is service to the medical profession.
I believe that our industry has done an outstanding job
in developing and making available the drugs which help our doctors help us.
The expenditures of our industry for medical research and development
run well over a hundred million dollars annually.
And of the medicine prescribed last year,
more than half could not have been prescribed 10 years ago simply because they did not exist.
Thank you.
[Narrator:] Now across the breadth of Southwest Asia to Lebanon,
crossroads of the middle east, sweeps the March of Medicine.
[Music]
Here on the Mediterranean sits Beirut,
cultural capital of the Arab nations.
And on the campus of its most famous institution,
we are greeted by the Foreign Minister of Lebanon, Dr. Charles Malik.
[Dr. Malik:] This all around me here is the American University of Beirut.
I am a graduate to this university.
It is an American University in more than name.
It is American both in its democratic spirit and in its educational philosophy.
It seeks to train its students to think freely,
to value truth, and to live by principle.
This is certainly true of its medical school, founded in 1867,
before Pasteur and Lister had made their revolutionary discoveries.
[Narrator:] The medical school that opened with 14 students
now trains scores from all over the Middle East.
The teaching staff, some of whom have trained in the United States,
is drawn chiefly from Lebanon, but includes several American physicians.
Heading the international faculty is an American, the Dean of the Medical School.
American doctors teach pharmacology,
anesthesiology,
obstetrics and gynecology,
surgery,
and ophthalmology,
all helping to train a student body that will spread the benefits of their medical education
throughout this entire region of the world.
Training goes on too in Lebanon's villages each summer,
villages which often lack a suitable water supply.
Here the students do fieldwork in preventive medicine in public health,
under the direction of an American doctor who conducts these clinics
that they may learn to help improve sanitary facilities
and raise health standards.
Now, typical of many students who are the product of this high quality of medical education
is this young lady, Miss...or should I say Doctor, Nermeen Tutungi.
Dr. Tutungi, where do you come from?
[Dr. Tutungi:] Amman.
[Dr. Malik:] You come from Amman in Jordan.
Your brother was here too?
[Dr. Tutungi:] I have two sisters and two brothers
who have graduated from this university.
[Dr. Malik:] What do they do now?
[Dr. Tutungi:] My brother, one of them is with working in the obstetrics department here.
My other brother went to the States,
to Emory University in Georgia to specialize in cardiology.
My sister is working [?] in Jordan.
[Dr. Malik:] And what are your plans?
[Dr. Tutungi:] I'm planning to go to the States next year to specialize in surgery.
[Dr. Malik:] And then what do you expect to do?
[Dr. Tutungi:] Our original plan was to go back to Jordan,
each one with a specialty, and operate a hospital.
[Dr. Malik:] Very good, Dr. Tutungi, thank you very much.
Dr. Tutungi will, as she told us, carry back to her own land
the skills, techniques, and designs that she has been able to learn here
at the university,
thus helping to build a better, a healthier,
and a happier world for her own countrymen.
[Music]
[Narrator:] Next, south to the African continent goes MD International,
over the Red Sea, Egypt and the Sudan, to Ethiopia.
In the mountain city of Gondar,
a few low-lying buildings give testament to cooperation
for health among nations as well as individuals.
Here our International Cooperation Administration,
with the Ethiopian government,
the World Health Organization, and UN Children's Fund,
has established a hospital.
Under the Director, Dr. Brooks Ryder of ICA,
young Ethiopians are trained as health officers,
community nurses, and sanitarians.
At the thatched village of Kaladupa,
an hour or more away, where the first of many planned health centers has taken root,
the students who are the hope of Ethiopia's future
practice preventive medicine by fighting the anopheles mosquito
that carries the dread malaria.
Here, among the descendants of the people of the Queen of Sheba,
people of Hamidic origin speaking a language known as Amharic,
American doctors seek to transfer their knowledge.
Doctors like Arthur Curtis who heads ICA's Health Mission in Ethiopia,
a long, long way from Arkansas
and his oldtime job of directing a division of the state health department.
Such health problems as are spawned by a primitive water supply,
often secured from unclean streams,
are now being assaulted by drilling wells deep in the ground.
[Music]
To the people, the bringing in of a new well represents
a hard-won victory over the threat of disease.
[Music]
So that an elevated water tank, far from spelling an eyesore,
seems a thing of beauty.
Such is the progress born of international cooperation,
symbolized by His Excellency, the minister of health,
planning even greater projects with an American doctor.
And nowhere is this more warmly felt than in the city
and behind the royal gates of Addis Ababa.
Here where his pet lion occasionally wanders the palace yard,
one whose determined fight for freedom
once moved the democratic world speaks his own feelings.
His Imperial Majesty Haile Selassie the First, Emperor of Ethiopia,
King of Kings, elect of God and conquering lion of Judah.
[Emperor speaks in Amharic]
[Narrator, translating:] We are grateful for the cooperation of your doctors.
They have come at our invitation, far from home,
in order to pass on their medical skills to our own people.
Perhaps in no field does American cooperation have a more personal meaning for us
since it directly touches the lives and well-being of our citizens.
[Music]
Finally across the wide span of the Arabian Sea
to Vellore in South India marches MD International.
This is Vellore's Christian Medical College,
sponsored in part by more than 20 church groups in the United States,
but actually the dream come true of one woman,
granddaughter of the first American medical missionary to India,
Dr. Ida B. Scudder.
[Dr. Scudder:] I certainly am very, very happy to be here this afternoon
and to welcome you young people as students in this medical college.
When we started, you know,
we had one student,
and we've grown and grown and until we have so many.
I'm getting rather old, but I'm very happy to be here with this group today,
and I hope I should be here when you all graduate.
And I hope you young people are going to go out
and do great things for India and be representative of Vellore wherever you are.
[Narrator:] To the villages surrounding Vellore,
student doctors trained under an international staff
move out in a mobile clinic to take the benefits
of their clinic to their people.
Founder Ida Scudder's niece, a doctor in her own right,
accompanies this clinic on its journey,
supervising the emergency work conducted at bus side
and checking those patients who need her special attention.
[Music]
Besides carrying doctors to people, the mobile clinic carries its own pharmacy,
dispensing modern medications to those long dependent
on a few remedies found in nature.
Many line up, too, to register their children for treatment for scabies,
a skin infection caused by a small itch mite,
often combatted in special campaigns of Vellore's rural health program.
Once the way is cleared to the infectious areas,
all bedlam breaks loose as the children are scrubbed
with course coconut fibers to remove the diseased tissue.
After they are treated, like newly washed laundry,
they are put out in the sun to dry.
[Music]
In hands warped by leprosy, desperately clutching the air in exercise along the roadside,
are the medical problems of India also reflected.
Hope for such hands and those of India's million other lepers
is found here in these hands at Vellore,
undergoing special treatment by British orthopedic surgeon Paul Brand.
[Dr. Brand:] These are leprosy patients, most of them uninfectious,
although all of them have some hand deformity,
and they're getting mobilized in preparation for surgery.
Here's a lad you see, who's got typical claw-hand.
He can't get the hand out straight because these four muscles are paralyzed.
Now this boy had the same kind of hand, more or less,
but he's had a reconstructive operation.
You can see the scar back there.
We took one of his good muscles in the forearm,
and we took a tendon graft from his leg,
and put the tendon graft right through his hand to each finger,
and now you can see he's got...
[Student:] But won't that muscle also get paralyzed?
[Dr. Brand:] Well, that's a good point but no, it won't.
We've surveyed several thousands of these hands now,
and we find that in leprosy,
there's an absolutely precise pattern of relatus.
It always hits certain muscles and always spares certain muscles.
[Student:] Is that a pattern you worked out here at Vellore?
[Dr. Brand:] That's right. Now this boy's had an operation on his other hand three weeks ago,
so in about a month's time he should be fit for doing good work.
And that's really the important thing,
you see, these men, you can cure them of leprosy now,
but what's the use of being cured of leprosy
if you've got a deformed hand and an ugly face and you can't get back to your family,
you can't get back to your job?
So by giving them new noses and new eyebrows and working fingers,
they can take a job and they can go back to normal lives.
[Narrator:] In the hospital in Vellore, a serious operation proceeds
under a doctor from Boston.
A four-year old child suffering from a heart defect
with which he was born,
undergoes what is known as a Blalock-Taussig, or blue baby, operation
to restore more normal blood circulation,
a type of surgery never performed at Vellore until the arrival of thoracic surgeon Dr. Reeve Betts.
Assisted by Dr. Gopinat, soon to study in the States,
and other members of the Indian staff,
Dr. Betts introduces a new and needed blood supply to the exposed heart
by bringing down an artery to the arm and joining it to an artery to the lung.
The entire procedure is observed by student doctors
in constant training under the new chest surgery teaching program.
Dr. Betts checks the newly introduced blood flow
by comparing the color of his fingernails with the fast returning color of the child's.
[Voiceover:] And Jesus commanded him to be brought unto Him saying, what would thou that I should do unto thee?
And he said Lord, that I may receive my sight.
[Narrator:] In the same spirit Dr. Victor Rambo dedicates his life and medical talents that the blind may see.
Raised in Nebraska and Wyoming,
schooled in Kansas and Pennsylvania,
Dr. Rambo initiated Vellore's eye camp,
a means of carrying eye surgery out into the field by trailer to treat those who otherwise might never come
to experience the healing power of medical science.
[Music]
Wherever a makeshift clinic can be set up for a few days,
he brings relief to the many thousands in India blinded by cataracts,
the clouding of the lens inside the eye.
Entering the eye made insensitive by anesthesia,
Dr. Rambo goes down behind the iris,
grasps the clouded lens at the bottom with his forceps,
rocks it free of its moorings and tumbles it up and out.
Later on glasses will provide an artificial lens to substitute for the one removed.
Few men are more dedicated to their task in life
and more enthusiastic about it then Dr. Victor Rambo.
[Dr. Rambo:] I've just taken the cataracts out of an old man
who we wouldn't have reached if we hadn't come out,
on the 350th eye camp, out to the villages of India
where most of the people of India live,
and where there are a million people blind
whom our surgery doesn't reach.
Now our surgery should reach all of these,
so we are, for the love of God and the friendship of the American people,
and the friendship of the Indian people,
joining together to really try and reach the very fellow in the village
and we are glad that are reaching him.
[Narrator:] One by one,
sometimes the number totaling as many as a hundred operated on in a single day,
the patients, their eyes bandaged and protected from infection
by drops of an antibiotic, are brought out and temporarily placed in the courtyard
of the improvised hospital to rest...to rest and wait for the coming of the light,
light that will remove the burden of darkness from them
that so long has made them an object of pity,
and save them from a lifetime of begging,
the traditional occupation of the blind.
This, to these, is the true meaning of the surgeon's mask,
of the instruments that boil on the kerosene stove and the needle that gave them peace.
A week or so later Dr. Rambo returns to the patients he left in care of a small staff,
returns to remove the stitches from the operated eyes and check their progress.
To conserve time he works over two patients at once.
The bandages are permanently removed,
but the shields are reapplied and worn for about two more days.
[Birds singing]
In one eye after the other he finds the promise of what is to come.
Finally, the day to receive their glasses, glasses that will be their new windows on the world,
a world with darkness vanished, hope rekindled, spirit reborn.
[Music]
This then is the time for parting, the time for thank you and goodbye
in ways far more expressive than words to the tall spare doctor from America.
As he stands there, in a remote village of India, surrounded by the sick he healed,
see in your mind's eye the multiplication of him throughout the whole world,
and discover not only the blind, homeward bound, seeing again,
but all the earth's peoples seeing that there is hope for peace
when man is his brother's keeper.
[Music]
The March of Medicine,
presented by the American Medical Association
in cooperation with Smith, Kline and French Laboratories.
Produced for the Medical Television Unit, Smith, Kline and French Laboratories.
[Music]